the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this video i want to do something a
little different
i don't know how many of you are like me
but ever since game of thrones ended
i have been wondering what all of the
characters could do next
now i know the show is over but that
doesn't mean these characters have to
die
in my mind they are still living their
lives so i started thinking about what i
would do with the characters if i were
writing the next season
i do have a few ideas that i still
haven't fully fleshed out yet but i
figured i could do that as i go alone
now i'm not making this video because i
think i'm some great writer or anything
like that
in fact i would actually say the
opposite about myself but i won't let
that stop me from having some fun
so in this video i will go over my
version of the new season 4 game of
thrones
and keep in mind i'm writing this based
on how things ended in the final season
i am making myself begin right where hbo
left off
now let's get into it my version of the
first episode of season 9 will be named
a new awakening
the first episode will start with a cold
opening so before the opening credits
and theme song
even begin we will be jumping right into
the first scene
we will be immediately thrown into a
flashback scene and i will let you know
right up front
all of this will foreshadow some of the
major events from the season
in the first flashback scene we are back
inside the three-eyed ravens cave
we will see brain stark the three-eyed
raven and leaf having a conversation
hodor and mira reed are off screen
sitting outside the cave
where we have seen them sit before this
is when we will see the three-odd raven
and leif explain how brain's visions
will work
what they say to him is lifted right out
of the books although i did make some of
my own minor changes
we hear the three ed ravens say a
weirwood will live forever
if left undisturbed for them seasons
come and go in the flutter of a bird's
wing
and past present and future are one
nor will your sight be limited to your
god's wood the singers carved eyes into
their heart trees to awaken them
and those are the first eyes a new
greenseer learns to use
in time you will be able to see well
beyond the trees themselves
now remember what was said here because
this has major implications for bran
stark's abilities
this lets us know bran won't always need
the werewoods for him to be able to see
things
it also indicates he might be able to
see future events as well
then we cut to another flashback scene
now we see a massive red building
and standing outside of that building is
hundreds of followers overlore
who are all dressed in red robes all of
them are looking at the sky
but we can't quite make out what they're
looking at after a few moments we see a
giant shadow
in the shape of a dragon fly right over
top of them
they look happy for its arrival the
flashback goes to the next scene
now we see arya stark in the woods
surrounded by wolves
this was when she reunited with nymeria
and all we get is a glimpse of this
then it flashes to the next scene brian
stark is inside the old throne room of
the red key
we're not able to hear anything at first
but we can see he's having a
conversation with a large man dressed in
house stark's brown leathers with a
horrific looking scar
on his face as soon as brain signals for
the man to step in closer
we're suddenly able to hear what he says
next in a low voice
bran says when you return i will make
you the master of whisperers
then we go to another flashback scene
now we're back inside the three-eyed
ravens cave
we are looking through the eyes of a
raven we don't see anyone inside
other than some dead bodies and the
bones on the ground
it looks like the inside of the cave was
on fire most of the roots of the
werewolf are now blackened with ash
the raven takes flight and we begin
going deeper into the cave
where no living man has gone before some
of you might not know this but the
three-eyed raven's cave is actually
massive it's not only one level like we
saw in game of thrones
it goes down deep into the earth the
raven is now flying through complete
darkness
after what feels like several minutes
the raven finally lands inside a chamber
we've never seen before
there are lots of candles burning along
the wall
the floor is covered in what looks like
hundreds of years worth of melted wax
in the back of the chamber there are
roots of the werewood shaped into three
weirwood thrones
the raven flaps across the room and he
begins walking up and down the roots of
the weirwood
when the bird looks down we can see
there are three very old members of the
children of the forest
they have long white hair with very long
white beards
at first they look like they're dead but
right before the flashback scene ends
one of them opens his eyes scaring the
raven away
now these next few scenes happen really
fast now we're in winterfell's godswood
we hear bran say to jaime how do you
know there isn't afterwards
what about afterwards how do you know
there is an afterwards
then we see john stabbed daenerys in
front of the iron throne
then we see brain and king's landing we
hear him say
why do you think i came all this way
will you lead the seven kingdoms to the
best of your abilities
from this day until your last day
why do you think i came all this way
we see ned stark behead the night's
watch deserter
we see the iron throne before it was
melted
then we hear bran say to john you are
exactly where you were supposed to be
i'm sorry i wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
now some of these scenes indicate bran
stark knew what would happen in the end
now we're back inside the three odd
ravens cave we hear leaf explain
why they created the night king
we were being slaughtered our sacred
trees cut down
we needed to defend ourselves from whom
from you in this final flashback scene
we see the night king when he laid his
finger on the face of one of craster's
sons
we're about to finally see what happens
after this
when the baby's eyes became blue the
night king gets back on his horse
while holding the baby we see him as
well as all the other white walkers ride
back to their castle in the lands of
always winter
we follow them as they walk inside the
castle then down a flight of stairs
they enter what looks like a crypt
similar to winterfell's the only
difference is
everything in this castle is either made
out of ice or carved into it
the night king bends down to set the
baby on a large block of ice
right as the night king stands back up
we get a better view of just how big
this crypt actually is
what it really looks like is an
underground mine shaft that stretches
out like very long fingers
into many different directions it makes
one wonder where they all lead
because you can only see so far into the
dark but this isn't the most shocking
reveal
right over the night king's shoulder we
can see there are dozens of babies
laying on blocks of ice
the blocks are in single file lines
stretching down each one of the shafts
until they disappear into the darkness
the flashbacks end when we cut to bran
stark sitting in the chair
his eyes are still rolled back in his
head but there's something different
about them
they're not as white as they used to be
they have somewhat of a blue haze to
them
after a few moments they flip back to
normal then we immediately
cut to the opening theme
like i said before all of these
flashback scenes will happen in the very
first episode before the opening credits
all of them foreshadow some of the major
events that will happen in this season
now i know it took me several minutes to
explain what happened in all of the
scenes but you have to imagine how fast
all of this would happen if you saw it
on the screen yourself
each of the scenes would fly by really
fast because you would be able to see
and hear everything without me having to
describe it all
now what i think i will do is upload the
opening scene by itself first
just to get a feel for how many of you
want to see me continue making them
i thought about writing out the entire
first episode but a lot of you might not
even want to watch something like this
so before i go investing any more time
into writing out the episodes i want to
see how many of you are
interested in seeing what else i would
do for the following season
if you want to see me finish the first
episode as well as the rest of the
season
let me know down below if you hate this
idea then i can just stop right now
before i go any further
the subscribers will decide how far i go
with this
either way thanks for watching what i
have written thus far
as always i hope all of you have a great
day i will see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]